well first of all I'm going to have
nightmares after that hearing you saying
closer closer and yes sir I don't want
to see you uh tonight anywhere close to
me close by the way we do have David
Brodsky back-to-back victories David
against a wonder the rating favorite as
well as Christopher you the lead The
Leader by by far of the tournament
tournament simply blue
wide open how
and what that's what Christopher did
last year when he beat Hans in round
eight
so yeah now I've
I'm here to spoil the tournament with
the black pieces and you did now tell us
a bit about the preparation that went
into this game because you guys uh went
into this very topical line very main
line of the open rui Lopez and it felt
like he surprised you
I was the one who was supposed to
surprise him because I haven't played
five in three years so I had those
preparation was quite quite interesting
because I just I I spent a lot of time
brushing up on stuff and I didn't even I
wasn't even sure I played E4 so
and then I came to the board and
realized I don't really remember
anything here I know just know there was
some tabatabai game in this and the
engine say it's about equal exactly it's
kind of a novel uh approach by why to
give up the exchange like this but a
very dangerous one now Knight to C4
seems to have been maybe even novelty
Queen takes D1 was uh the move played
previously Queen takes D1 or take Z1
Knight C4 and then play just uh that end
game how did you feel about this end
game and why did you shy away sure okay
let's say Bishop C1 yes and rook d8 and
rookie one and it remains a very complex
sentence yeah
white is looking quite well yeah I don't
like this
but okay I remember the topic again
there was some weird repetition but
white declined and ended up losing I I
I'll need to look at that because
it was just blanking here and he chose
to play this move Knight to C4 Queen to
E2 came uh this seems to have been the
first move that surprised Christopher
Queen D7 how did you uh come up with
this concept of trying to kill the queen
centralized
well I mean he wants to he wants to do
something to my to my king side and I
also have to worry about the C4 Knight
because okay if if he plays something
that Bishop F4 and B3 then my Knight's
getting my Knight's getting kicked out I
mean I was originally thinking I'd take
only three Queen takes E3 Queen D7
something like this I wasn't so sure
it's just okay I think he probably
you might still go with five it's just
very very complicated cool Queen D5
and now okay if he can just get the Rook
to the H far I think he's mating me
exactly more or less exactly I'm not
sure if he can do it so G3 yeah
something to just play something like G3
and
yeah I don't know like it's not coming
too fast but I'm not sure what to do
with wow can you stop it yeah how do I
stop it yeah exactly so I thought okay
I'm gonna go Queen D7 without which is
you know I mean I obviously want to
centralize my Queen if I want to stop
the attack and I'm also attacking G4 I
mean okay let's Bishop page seven that's
a queen size I wasn't sure what's
happening there but yeah I expected
Bishop of five Queen D5 and I was very
surprised that he'll let me play Knight
takes B2 exactly I was like he usually
doesn't blunder like this and I think it
was a shocker when you play the move
Knight B2 for him as well he seemed uh
destabilized at that point yeah I know
this is this is my whole idea basically
and queen D5 which before Knight takes
B2 and if Bishop before I'd go we should
D4 I'd go C5 and I think I'd give back
the exchange in Aid
Bishop E4 and just give up the exchange
yeah Queen E6 let's say
okay Bishop A8 now yeah I can I can take
an eight or I can take an D4 I think
take on D4 is better second D4 so if
Knight D4 Queen H6
that that's just a piece right that's a
piece yeah so he has to go somewhere
with the bishop let's say Bishop B4
after CD4 Bishop B4
okay I'm gonna take in C3
if he plays Bishop of five I have
internet so CB2
it's a funny one so bc3 and then I
thought okay Queen no if 95 then I'm
done but I can say country 4 instead
well that's good that should be fine
this should be fine like equal material
I have another Knight on C4 yeah I don't
see the I mean it's good for me and what
if he plays G3 instead of Bishop F4 did
you calculate this uh oh just just very
just slow G3 maybe that's that's
probably the engine move right I have no
idea actually uh okay what happens if I
take an E5
wait well that's a good question it's
just losing for flight maybe it is yeah
yeah it's funny you know rookie one
almost tracks my queen but at Knight
takes E3 in this position I don't know
if you can exploit that somehow very
nice 963 okay
Queen oh I can I can take it to I can
also go Queen C4 if I want to control
thing but actually yeah I can take a
free Pawn why not
excellent then he played this move
Bishop to F4 and after Knight to B2 you
guys entered this very uh almost four
sequence yeah yeah 95 like I thought it
was good for me but I underestimate in
95. like I thought he's gonna take an F7
Bishop E6 but then okay he doesn't have
the bishop pair now one thing about
Knight D5 and the exchange of the queens
and then you guys got this position
after Bishop yeah actually to each one
you started shaking your head here you
seem distressed I don't know what was
the reason well actually I'm okay if we
go back even Bishop F6 was not an easy
move to make so first of all there's
there's something very funny originally
I thought if he goes F6 that he just
takes and sees if I play F6 I thought
originally okay he takes in C6 and he
has good compensation but I realized
that no he can actually the bishop H7
King H7 Rook H1 King G8 Knight G6 oh
let's go oh that's nice and it's just
Nate that's just me wow you know I never
seriously consider it F6 but then I saw
this like wow this is funny it'd not be
funny if it happened to me I'd be
quitting chess but
but that's really nice and it yeah
instead of F6 I also considered moves
like G6 and G5
but anyway so yeah G5 is interesting I
thought like GF ef7 King G7
Bishop E3
yeah I thought Bishop yeah Bishop F6
and the game gets pretty wild it's
pretty wild I wasn't sure about going
into this I might probably has other
options so I decided okay let's keep it
simple with Bishop F6 should be fine for
me all right let's keep going Bishop to
F6 he's a very rich game very very
Regional full of content and you guys
entered this end game Bishop to A4
immediately blissed out night way for it
you have this uh under control but also
you spotted this from afar uh this whole
line I think I saw I forget when I saw
94 but it's it's a pretty nice move you
just take through the night and I hear
actually I wasn't sure how much I had
because I thought it was good but then I
started 85 was uh the computers move
just cut the Rook away then defend the
portal with King G7 and then basically
the pawn on eight oh oh wow oh wow yeah
King G7
oh wow that is yeah how did I not see
that and it's easy to look at an engine
because here's visual indeed okay but
you how did you assess this one okay I
was shocked when you played it for it
you were expecting him to take on G5
yeah I thought okay this is like Black's
obviously for choice but I think white
should hold like he has the resources to
stop the pods just a little okay Rick a
two
let's say actually F4 was a very
interesting move right now oh he can
even yeah he can even play just to give
you the pawn now the point being that if
you take on G2 I go Rook F5
okay now whenever you go on the e-file I
go back to G5 and then you have to come
back to the file oh wow I didn't see it
in this version I thought he goes Rook
at five instead of f4
which is pretty sensible in my opinion
yeah this this is nice this is nice yeah
yeah he did not even spend too much time
on this he he played that for quite
quickly I was I don't understand why you
don't want to go into that that game
okay Bishop six and now I I messed up
here I I okay I thought I I'm blundered
kind of so I played B4
here before Jesus yeah Jesus is a
question mark yeah my plan was to go
kingy8 but then I saw the white has this
diabolical mover D6 diabolical he
started he's running Bishop G5 and he
responds to me that's a Checkmate yeah
and I I didn't know what to do here
Bishop F6 rookie six
oh and now if you go on the D file it
takes on F6 if you go on the you are
actually losing now yeah so I saw this I
was like wow this is amazing like I
don't know I don't know what to do after
56. uh maybe I'm missing okay maybe I
don't know what to do
so maybe seven you have to but that B4
is probably a mistake but okay it's very
shaky but we get into this okay so I
thought okay I probably just have to
allow this and I had no okay this is
very hard to assess honestly it's just
raw calculation it's winning it's
winning okay okay I wanna I wanna check
some things yes because so Bishop C
Bishop C3 okay this is forced four to
six okay now I thought for a very long
time which as I should okay A5 I hope it
doesn't blow it yeah [ __ ] okay Bishop
fade is bad no don't don't go I thought
Bishop D4 okay it was critical okay
let's say Bishop D4 King E6 oh yeah or
E7 doesn't matter G7
G7 King F7 now King E3
this gets this gets interesting so so
the most primitive line is if I just
push the pawn A4 King D3
A3 A3 yeah so now if King C4 then Rook
B2 wins that was that's what I thought
but I didn't see a win after King to C3
instead of uh King C4
what the difference because if Bishop
Rook B2 then Bishop C5 right
nice and if Rook A1 then King B3
um I I didn't I thought I'm just losing
the pawn here and if you
take on G2 then just okay B3 and King 82
he's gonna win the pawn back yeah or he
can maybe even hold it if he doesn't
want to play Rick versus Bishop
so this is yeah this is no this this so
this is crazy stuff so instead I decided
that
I decided that I'm gonna play without
play uh Rook C2 instead of uh
yeah yeah we're looking at table base
okay was this the position that uh no I
I wasn't I didn't think I had the sort
of four to take on G2 but okay you can
you can oh I can't afford to take on yes
okay so A4 let's okay look at this one
yeah three three but somehow in our
analysis this part was already gone
right so yeah King C3 King C3 this is
already dropped yes yes so you actually
start with Rook takes G2 okay no I
thought actually I didn't say Rook G2 I
thought I'm gonna I thought I'm gonna
play Rook C2 instead of uh A4 I I don't
I don't own this check Rick's Rook C2
here King D3 King D3 oh it's it's
winning okay it's still winning it's
still winning okay now Rook Rook Street
no no I thought yeah Rook C6 somewhere
C8 doesn't really matter
um Bishop C3 the instincts to run A4
King C2 now if A3 King B3 he's in time
no he's not he's not apparently not what
am I missing A2 A2
it's your Bishop some Bishop somewhere
okay six you don't have the B2 Square
so you're just okay so I could have so
yeah this is probably what happens when
you calculate so deeply I'm gonna
accidentally find find a win somewhere
okay okay and is is A3 the only winning
move because I was wondering uh is this
someone similar to the game if I can
play rugby six here
V6 is a drop okay it's a draw so I
probably would have okay I probably
right here I probably would have found
this this idea that A3 actually wins
David congratulations back-to-back
victories against uh terrific
competitions congratulations you're
definitely playing the spoilers role in
this one we'll see you tomorrow yeah
thank you well done indeed Bravo beating
the tournament leader who had scored six
and a half uh pardon me uh five and a
half out of six he could have